18:56 and Britton is unhappy with China
the reason for this was the China having
recently been defeated in the previous
opium war was supposed to give
concessions to Britain which had yet to
do another issue was that British
consumption of tea was so great that
Britain was operating a huge trade
deficit with China
the only thing salvaging British
finances was the continued sale of opium
into China from British India another
problem was that China was currently
dealing with the Taiping rebellion whose
leaders kept destroying opium wherever
they found it the sale of opium into
China was vital for balancing Britain's
finances and so it had to keep flowing
in late 1856 the governor of count on Yi
Ming Chen impounded a Chinese operated
ship that he believed was committing
piracy or at least was working on behalf
of the rebels one problem though the
ship was registered in Hong Kong now a
British territory and as a result the
British were furious frankly the British
consul to China
Harry Parkes was hitching for another
war there because he wanted to make a
name for himself he offered to give the
sailors back but Britain said no and
sailed the Royal Navy up the Pearl River
and shelled Canton back in Britain
Parliament was fiercely against any war
with China but the Prime Minister Lord
Palmerston was very much for it
parliament voted against any further
action mostly because of the outbreak of
a major mutiny in India in 1857 as a
result Palmerston called an election and
after denouncing the Chinese as
barbarians to the British people he won
and so war it was an alliance was built
with the French because they also wanted
to trade with China but the Americans
after taking the fort in late 1856
declared the neutrality and Russia
wanted nothing to do with it because
they were still recovering from the
Crimean War so the war in China the
Second Opium War followed a similar path
to the first the Royal Navy used their
ironclad steam-powered warships to
obliterate the Chinese wooden ships
called junks wherever they met in late
1857 anglo-french forces captured Canton
and captured Yi he was then imprisoned
in India after this the British and
French Navy's made their way up the
coast of China harassing the defenders
and smashing forts as they went the
Chinese emperor the Jian Feng emperor of
the Ching dynasty soon after opted to
suit for peace the negotiations resulted
in the Treaty of Tianjin which gave
France Russia the US and Britain the
right to trade and for their citizens to
freely travel throughout China the US
and Russia were allowed to get in on the
action despite not fighting because it
meant that if China backed down on their
agreements it would risk retaliation
from all four powers plus Russia had
just negotiated the transfer of this
territory the Ching didn't want another
front to fight on one problem when they
go
haters went to Beijing to ratify this
truce in 1859 they were kidnapped and
tortured by the Chinese government this
for the British was proof that their
opinion of the Chinese as being little
more than barbarians was justified the
commander of the British forces in China
the Earl of Elgin was actually against
the war but after the capture of the
negotiators he felt that he had to
retaliate to protect Britain's honor the
British and French then landed their
forces in the north and captured many
forts on the way to Beijing they soon
clashed with a large Qing army at the
Battle of pala cow they saw her over a
thousand Chinese casualties compared to
about 50 on the anglo-french side the
Chinese had now lost the will to pursue
the war mostly because of again the
ongoing Taiping rebellion after the
battle the Emperor fled Beijing leaving
his brother Prince gong to negotiate
with the Europeans anglo-french forces
there moved on Beijing which opened its
gates to them after which the most
famous event of the war happened the
Allied soldiers forced their way into
and looted the Emperor's Summer Palace
and when Elgon found out the Chinese had
killed many of the envoy's he ordered it
burned to the ground
the Chinese then signed the 1860 Treaty
of Beijing which did several things it
confirmed the 1858 treaty increased the
reparations that China would pay gave
Russia more territory and also saw
Britain gain slightly more land around
Hong Kong interestingly this war is
called the Second Opium War but OPM's
role was largely secondary this time it
was about enforcing open trade and
demonstrating to China that Europeans
were now the dominant ones in the region
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching and a special
thanks to all of these patrons you see
on screen for their generosity in
supporting the show and a particularly
special thanks to James Bissonnette
party-boy Co Michael Reynolds Gustav
Swann Winston Cawood Skye Chappell Adam
Harvey Gable airy and azekah flash
you